Albert one thing you said to me early on
in the campaign is actually pre campaign
but you said something like the Swiss
had to run referendum on women's right
to vote 16 times before it passed or
something along those lines yeah and
you're you and you made that comparison
because you were like we should start
running out ubi now with the thought
that it might take more than one try and
I remember hearing this and I just loved
the the long-term thinking you had where
it wasn't like hey is Andrew yang going
to be in the White House it was more
like hey let's let's get the first
rutted because it might take multiple
tries yeah it might be worth zooming out
for a moment you know the the this ubi
isn't a panacea it is one ingredient in
a larger transition and what is that
larger transition it's the transition
out of the Industrial Age so the biggest
mistake that politicians in many
countries not just the US have been
making for probably the last 10 maybe
the last 20 years is to treat digital
technology and computers as if it was
just an extension of the Industrial Age
this transition that we're going through
is as profound as when we went from
being fortress to agrarian society and
then from agrarian society to industrial
society and so those transitions took
long periods of time and they were
multi-generational projects and they
require it the wholesale reinvention of
how people live and so ubi is super
important it's a cornerstone but it's
not the only thing that we need to think
about when we talk about how we get past
the Industrial Age and so it's crucial
to have a larger vision and you know
part of the how we wind up with certain
sort of regressive political movements
at the moment in many democracies is
because we've left this vacuum where for
a decade or more we've been saying look
a little tweak of the interest rate here
and a little bit of retraining over
there and
everything will be good and where most
people sit that's just not true
most people saying that you keep saying
that but it's just not working right and
so we we need to paint a broader picture
of a future and Susan mentioned the
spark of Hudson earlier that is also
part of that broader picture which is
who has access to knowledge how do you
bring knowledge to everybody including
people who've been excluded from it for
a long period of time yeah so that's why
we're working on the Workforce
Development Program we're working on
trying to get the infrastructure in
Hudson up to speed with transportation
so that people can actually get to the
work that there may exist so all the
different parts and and and also that
the connectivity infrastructure so
people have high-speed access and
fundamentally changing you know where
and how you can learn right so we have
set up a system where the presumption is
that you need to go to school in order
to learn and then ideally you go from
school to some like fancy college and if
you don't do that you somehow like not
smart not worth II can't learn things
and we believe that that's just not true
that people can learn things they can
learn them at different ages in
different ways and that you know a big
thrust of digital technology is to let
people learn things at any point um you
know including much later in life now
more than ever you know your kids again
are a bit older but I was in parts of
the country where they don't have
high-speed Internet and you can imagine
those kids now trying to learn I mean
there are so many kids that right now
are struggling academically because of
the fact that now I mean they've lost
months and we're looking at this fall
it's unclear what schools are gonna look
like but certainly having broadband
access to me is like a cornerstone in a
building block it's like how can you
make meaningful educational
opportunities available if someone like
that they're not even going to be able
to plug in in a real way so one thing
that you all have been very passionate
about which I think most everyone
listening this is going to agree with is
that so you have one corner
Universal basic income and then climate
change is something else that you've
been very passionate about and working
on and so Susan I'd love to ask you
something that I just saw an article and
it made me almost jump for joy where
someone who's an environmental activist
said hey universal basic income might
really be part of the solution lighting
up our environmental footprint so can
you talk about the work you all have
been doing on climate change and how you
see some of these income policies
impacting our ability to make progress
on a sustainable economy the relation to
ubi is a really interesting one first as
we talked about previously we'll let
more people be politically active and
get to solutions for the climate crisis
but the second thing is there's also
some evidence early evidence that ubi
changes people's view of consumption and
the way does that is that when you are
no longer in the scarcity mindset that
oh my god I can't afford anything
consumption actually starts to loom less
large and people's needs and and all the
sudden people go oh maybe I should learn
something instead or maybe I should put
some money aside or maybe I should
become engaged in something so um
there's a lot of evidence that the sort
of scarcity mindset that is forced upon
a lot of people makes it very difficult
to think beyond consumption and so much
of what we're applying ourselves to
unfortunately it's just you know
consumption and it's just making enough
money to keep consuming and so
disrupting that to pay the bills pay the
bill hit the put food on the table right
yeah so disrupting that is a crucial
aspect I made the same argument on the
trail one of my hopes was that if you
had the boot off of people's throats
where you got enough money where you
could meet your basic needs I thought
we'd have much more in the way of arts
and creativity and folks going to the
woods and working on a novel and whatnot
and adopting more minimalist type
lifestyles because they would have
different
goals for themselves in different
pursuits instead of driving and
commuting to their cubicle and doing job
X like you'd have more people doing
things and we're seeing that now in that
with covin right a lot of people are now
moving to the country and we're seeing
that they're not consuming as much as
they were that they're going out in
nature that they're enjoying it that
they're that they're doing activities
that as Albert said us are not
consumptive and there's a basic income
project in Germany that Susan that I've
been supporting for years that has a lot
of evidence to that same effect where
people really suddenly decrease their
consumption this is sometimes a an
objection that people bring up to ubi
they say people just gonna spend it on
more stuff but actually the evidence
goes the opposite direction that makes
me so glad because I was making that
argument on the trail probably best I
wasn't citing like some German data data
homegrown but like that the thing I was
suggesting was like look if you can
actually get the boot off of people's
throats they're going to be much more
energized around making different types
of choices and also be more attentive to
climate change because right now if
you're laboring under this constant
scarcity mindset and someone says you
need to worry about climate change and
you're like I'm worried about next
month's rent yeah you know it's like you
feel like like the earth or this
absolutely big grand problem that's
years away and then the human impulse is
to say a thought the bet is that it's
not that big a deal anyway like this is
just like the sort of defensive response
well and also the thing that we're
working on here at the farm is we're
trying to change the mindset of how
people view the climate crisis that you
know it could really be when you when
you work to be sustainable it can really
be something quite joyous where it's all
around sort of enjoying nature and well
yeah I mean it's the idea that we have
the means to overcome this crisis
without somehow all you know going back
and instead of living in a hovel right
and being dour about it we're having fun
while we're doing it
[Applause]
[Music]